you guys were swimming in a tank full of
old food like broccoli and milk it was
in milk to make it murky and it was warm
so they were like heated it was like
my mom said i smelled so bad i did like
after the shooting because i would find
broccoli like in areas that broccoli
should never be your skin was so pruning
oh thank you
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the on wax podcast
with your favorite sisters sophia and
sistine
let me have my name woman you can have
your name should we just change it now
you just say your name all the time do
you always i have a question
what who decided it was sophia and
sistine why not steen and sophia i have
a question why don't we not argue every
single time we do the intro it's kind of
just you know it's traditional tradition
yeah at this point okay guys how are you
doing happy tuesday happy tuesday y'all
i am feeling fabulous we have a very
exciting guest on today
um an old girlfriend of mine
i'm gonna wait to introduce her but i'm
really excited for you guys to hear that
part of the interview i'm feeling good i
don't know why today i woke up i mean i
always wake up excited to do the show
but i was really extra excited yeah i
don't know makes me happy being here i
know it does too i feel like everyone
here has just been super nice and i feel
like every time i walk in to see the sun
i'm like oh my gosh it's it's
crazy yeah being around a positive
environment what it can do for you
so it makes you want to work isn't that
a crazy idea having a great team makes
you like it's incredible it's incredible
i think i was just such a ba humbug
about l.a because i
clumped everyone into being just a
negative angry person all the time who
knew there were nice people out there
guys i know who knew who knew so
speaking of great vibes you know what's
coming up
halloween spooky scary skeletons and if
anyone knows the scene like i do you
would know that her favorite favorite
favorite holiday of all time is
halloween i
am
obsessed yes i love it i love everything
about it i
minimum have four costumes every year
every year but don't get invited to four
parties or or one actually this is the
thing we we order a lot of costumes yeah
but do you guys think we can invite to
any halloween party no no last year we
were just no not last year the year
before that we were just walking around
the streets we were we were literally
walking around the streets on halloween
my costume didn't help because i did
dress up as
a pretty woman but when she was the
hooker so i was quite literally
hooking on the streets hooking on the
look and all the streets man
but i think that why we love it so much
is we have a tradition every single year
so steve and i yes we have like our we
have our scary costume our sexy costume
and then
we have our funny costumes yes and we do
this tradition every single year we
decide what duo what what what can we
really hone in on and make it hilarious
i think we've had a pretty interesting
few years
four years ago we dressed up as the
lonely island dick in a box yes
justin timberlake actually commented on
our costumes you guys yeah
iconic that was the year i think we
peaked because we dressed up as the
lonely island and then jt was basically
saying i for already said you know what
he did he invited us to his concert
and
[Laughter]
and then the year after that we decided
to dress up as the inflatable tube men
outside of a car wash yes
i think i'm going to bring that one out
again this year didn't get enough love
no then we dressed up as um i was you
were the old fisherman that had a
missing arm and then i you were my
captain and i was like the rich guy on
the boat yes you were the i looked at mr
i called myself mr monopoly man yes yes
and then this year we're thinking let me
know what you guys think we're thinking
we do
305 mr worldwide people
we're thinking okay
a dollar
that's so hard to actually
what songs does he do i can't remember
oh yeah oh yeah timber
that's kesha yeah but he thinks he's in
it he's like down s
tim
full bald cap yeah full
i just think it would be hilarious oh
it'd be amazing but you know what last
year i wanted to do this with you and
you were not committed to it i thought
we would be the blue men group
no i'm not sure she wasn't into the body
painting okay does anyone want to cover
themselves head to toe and blue paint
for the content absolutely no for the
last for the shower no thank you i'm
fine with that but do you feel like like
when you see girls when they come in and
they're dressed as like sexy
uh nurses or do you think it's like like
do you think that what was my question i
actually had a good question i'll jump
off of what you're probably trying to
say when i see a girl dressed super um
overtly sexy at a halloween party i
think um you look hot yeah i think
honestly i love it because it's the one
night a year where you can get away with
dressing a little bit [ __ ] like your
inner the way you want to be but
can't because of
you know societal pressures or judgment
or whatever it may be you're allowed to
do it and get no judgment it's
incredible the best costume i've seen i
think that everyone is figuring out a
way to make anything sexy at this point
like anything yeah and so i saw do you
know the spongebob episode with patrick
starr and he's wearing the stockings yep
and the heel boots
that's a sexy halloween costume it's
sexy patrick's oh i saw a sexy pennywise
the clown the other day
which um
buying that
pennywise i was thinking this is my also
idea because i want to do scary but also
a little bit sexual
that's what we do uh
it's very on brand for me these days i
was thinking i want to dress up as the
grim reaper right i want to get a long
cape
with the hood and the giant sword thing
yeah but make it sexy call myself the
slim reaper put on a leotard under
instead yeah i do
so i thought this would be really funny
because i know you were like i'm gonna
do a scary one i want to tell you first
i thought okay why don't i be the
character in american horror story
that's like the full-blown zipper from
you know those scary like black you'll
just look like full dominated yeah and
then i thought honestly i'd scare myself
so then i thought you know what i'm
going to do the classic bed sheet cut
holes in my eyes and just walk around
that's the lamest costume exactly when
was the last thing you've seen anybody
just do that it's almost you're trying
too hard to be funny that it just
doesn't come across as funny you're mean
i know but it's it's one of those it's
like you know when someone is like
forcing a joke you're like all right
all right sistine
by the way
so many better ideas for you i literally
that person 365 days a year will write
down costume ideas for this week i
freaking am ready for it hot take
i like couple costumes
you
don't maybe it's because i'm bitter that
i've never been dating anyone during
college dude i think it depends on the
couple costume because i think some of
them can be a little bit cringey i want
to ask the people behind cameras what do
you guys think of a couple's costume
cringey and cringy
i agree i think
it depends on the costume that's the
thing it's like i liked the year that
everyone did i mean it got overdone but
when it was the joker and harley quinn i
thought that was super cool when you can
like really do it and well i have a
question pov
yeah you're in a
wonderful relationship that'd be nice
and
yeah go ahead
yeah take a seat take a seat back close
your eyes daydream a little bit
you're in a wonderful relationship
loving does everything right yeah he's
tall he's athletic he's a football
player on the ramps
what the hell is
fabulous right he does everything right
sophia baby i love you so much
i love you so much that i would love to
do a couple's costume with you i'll be
like and it would hold on and it would
make me
so happy if you did this
i'm going to dress up as a giant slice
of peanut butter toast and i want you to
be a giant slice of jelly
would you be a peanut butter and jelly
costume with him
he loves you he's a great guy
but wait you're making it seem like if i
say no you dump me
well is that the is that the problem i
haven't thought that far i've had but
would you do it
i would say this relationship is
definitely just not going to work whoa
whatever
sistine a peanut butter and jelly
so you won't do a couple of squash it's
worth the avocado and the avocado pit
i can't see i like when i see people do
the danny zuko and and whatever her name
is from greece
oh okay that's cute sandy sandy yeah you
should do that with uh no the guy that
you know being with actually i do not
like couples costumes
by the way my costumes are so well
thought out it's my time to shine you're
not getting credit i'm sorry it is my
costume okay so since we get invited to
know halloween parties i don't know if
anyone out there wants to invite us but
if you guys want to we're pretty fun it
would be nice
should we have should we throw something
are we just being lazy i think we should
also what if we just admit that
sometimes halloween is a little
overrated
for you
it is a little okay here's the little i
hate everything scary that's i love
scary yeah everything so that's why i
thrive right now this is my time to
shine
i think on halloween night we dress up
as mr 305.
okay so that's like the one that's the
most public i think we need to just walk
around and run around and just with bald
caps on i think we should we should do
it i'm excited so i actually wanted to
jump in really quick because we haven't
done a listener question in a while and
i
i don't know i miss like answering you
guys questions so we got one from andrea
and she said hey guys i love your
podcast and i was just wondering how you
did it my friend and i wanted to start
one but i have no clue order but where
to begin there goes my stuttering um
just any tips or anything i need to know
before i start would be great just a
quick reminder of how you can submit
your unsolicited advice questions go to
the apple podcast page give us five
stars and leave your questions in the
ratings and review section four stars
will be ignored too so far
we don't accept that anything lower five
stars but the question was how to start
a podcast her and her friend have wanted
to start one you want me to know let me
tell you exactly how to do it
you download an app that uploads all
your content what's up i i one i know is
fireside that was like the quickest so
we used fireside in the beginning
there's probably better ones out there
honestly look for one page that can
upload it but genuinely
sit down with your friend
have a clear vision about what you want
your podcast to be
have a clear title yeah and also
formulate your first episode practice in
the beginning with each other yeah if
you guys can't
swing off one of each other then you
guys shouldn't do a podcast i remember
what sophia and i did in the very very
very beginning of unwaxed was we got a
huge whiteboard we wrote down on wax at
the top and we just started spitballing
every sort of idea just words everything
that would sort of encapsulate what we
want the brand to be and then from that
we sort of got our little bio like
unapologetically unwaxed all that stuff
it came really naturally and then to
practice with the episode we would
actually have to drink to loosen up
because we got so in our heads about how
we sounded oh my god we stuttered oh we
cut each other off
just let it happen recording yourself
and your phone over and over and then
listening to it back really
teaches you how to
properly speak on the microphone but
overall just a reminder
it was pretty strenuous in the beginning
it wasn't something that was just
seamless and fluid and we just got this
podcast and it worked out we we spent at
least two months practicing and getting
it already so i just want you guys to
remember that if you are starting a
podcast and let's just say you've done
all that buy two microphones and get
started and honestly that's the first
step is just getting those things and
then the more times you do it the easier
it'll be yeah and if you look at it like
it's a fun thing to do with your friend
or your sister and treat it that way
then it comes off super organic and
natural and not everything he's gonna
say is going to be perfect we're going
to mess up we're going to fight but it's
fun it's all
leave it all in because i think people
like realness so enjoy it good luck tell
us if you need more advice
on that problem
oh you know also advice i should start
oh my god do you want to hear the
funniest thing ever
sophia we all know she's a great stalker
and i haven't done research no it's not
stuck this is so funny so sophia i
remember a few episodes back i think our
episode's called stalking 101
and she just came back with a whole page
of different ways to you know find your
mans
and one of them was stalk their linkedin
and i believe he used the quote
stalk their linkedin
if they're loyal to their company
they'll be loyal to you right yes
she finds out yesterday that there's
something called linkedin gold member
that allows the person to see
who's been researching them
you're [ __ ] bro
honestly
yeah kind of like how i think like 50 of
the people that i've researched
not stocked or researched yes
but can i say after that episode i did i
took a long hard look at myself in the
mirror and i have not done it since just
because i'm like this is really
unhealthy you're telling me you haven't
been on linkedin no i haven't i haven't
you haven't done your research bible
what's it what's your other form of
research now because i didn't his
instagram stock now
what profile are you using now what's
its name no i actually have none i
deleted it
so you're using your main profile yeah
yes i have graduated from youtube
they can find your email that's
associated with it i'm using my normal
instagram so they will see if it's me
now i'm just being shame like i'm not
shameless about like i'm just gonna do
it because i realized you guys maybe
stalking isn't the best thing to do and
also now i'm embarrassed because people
probably see me look at their linkedin
and maybe that's a compliment that i
wanted to see
with their career i don't know honestly
there's no way to take myself but i just
thought it was so funny so if you did
take sophia's advice to stock with
linkedin don't sign in i would stop
doing that don't sign in because they
will see
they will stay at their profile yeah and
it's not like a cute like oh she slid
into my dms or oh she like liked my old
photo no it's like
she's on my linkedin
she's on my linkedin that's pretty bad
um so today we have
an amazing guest joining us we have
corinne fox she is so talented
multifaceted we're gonna get into mental
health talk her relationship what she's
been up to if you guys are really
wanting to learn something about how to
balance
work dating um mental health all of this
stuff she's really she's kind of clean
at it and yeah it was a really fun
episode you actually there's a lot of
good tidbits that you can learn from it
and we also were both brought up um and
with a famous father and so we even jump
into that a little bit in the common
commonalities with it and also but
there's problems with stalking and
things like that but it's so amazing to
have her sit here in our studio and like
see that she really has made a name for
herself yeah and she's doing so well so
we will be right back with corinne
[Music]
you guys today we have actress executive
producer host of the tv show beach exam
and ambassador for the national alliance
on mental illness
as if that resume isn't impressive
enough you guys she is so sweet she's so
beautiful we have corinne fox joining us
today
wow i love the the round of applause oh
thank you for the applause of two you
also didn't say you're you're a co-star
well wait that's so i'm not going to put
myself in your intro it's your intro but
yeah
also co-star of 47 meters down on katie
let me tell you some beautiful memories
were made on that side was that the
first time you guys had met
no okay i was trying to figure this out
no because i remember when i got on set
you were like corinne i'm so happy
you're here i was telling all the girls
you're like gonna be such a great fit or
you're like who are you no but then i
was like how do we know each other but i
guess
i kind of came to the conclusion that it
may have been golden globe because we
were both miss golden globe yeah but
then also we did you did the dolce shows
too
yeah that's what it was but i don't know
if we ever actually crossed paths i
think it was one of the situations where
we always followed each other on
instagram so someone was like you know
them but even so and then i went to usc
and you went to ufc and like i don't
even think we crossed paths there i feel
like we're always in the same way we've
been orbiting each other for a while yes
and then when we got the movie together
it was just like oh yeah i know her but
then i was like did we actually
we are already best friends no that was
such a crazy funny time talking about
shooting that film together because we i
guess the first time we officially met
was in
dominican republic yeah
and i wasn't even originally like yeah
you came last minute yeah how was that
because i seen said to me that you came
like last minute and not the day before
that's a big transition to go from like
l.a to what you guys were doing like
swimming underwater nowhere
there was another girl they cast in it
never read for the part i don't know
what happened with her she dropped out
something happened well thank god no
offense to the girl but i'm happy she
was the girl and then they just called
me they're like can you go to the
dominican republic like it was like a
tuesday they're like can you get there
thursday and i was like okay okay and i
showed up i don't know how you just
showed up and killed it because i had at
least two major panic attacks
we're auditions too okay that's what i'm
saying first of all the auditions for
this were
i i don't i have to i have to post them
on on wax you guys are so funny i
remember
i have the i auditioned maybe eight
times
you did it was because i tried out for
every single character they made me try
for every character so i read for four
different girls and then i sent in two
self tapes and then they wanted me come
back in person and i was fake swimming
on the leg of a couch and i was just
trying to notice
i mean i don't have to post these no no
no i will i will but i was freaking out
because we had to get our scuba license
before i got over that which seems
insane that's what i want to ask you is
because i would just let that
i just remember her taking scuba lessons
and then talking about like her
screaming techniques all the time and
then you had to jump into that like
that's pretty scary and i'm a bad
swimmer you're you're a bad swimmer
shut up i had we had life vessels this
is actually a is a horrible summer i
can't tread but in comparison to me do
you remember my first day when i was
like i literally had a panic attack oh i
felt so bad yeah did you really yeah
because i lied to the director and they
were like oh can you swim blah blah blah
and i was like yeah like totally i just
want to wear something you know yeah
yeah and i get there and like the first
swim test like i barely i don't even
think i passed it and then the first day
on set we're like not even under water
we're just like swimming in this lake
and i'm like freaking the [ __ ] out oh i
would say it's
terrifying because i just discovered i
had the thing called the lassophobia
which is stuff laughing what is it the
fear of mechanical things underwater not
yeah just fear of like fish and sharks
and things you can't see under you oh
yeah like just be dangling under like
deep blue water yeah like you're saying
like that's terrifying but i remember
when that happened i felt so bad we were
supposed to i remember the director's
note was act like girls and do girl
things and splash each other we're like
okay but we were like drowning yeah but
well you were drowning drowning
we were like just splashing each other
and dunking each other and then you
started having a panic attack and i
couldn't tell if you were acting
like and having fun i was like wait
everybody used to stop filming for a
second i felt so bad but it ended up
being
um
one of the best experiences of my life
just being with you guys no it was like
really the like friendships we made and
with all the other girls and like we had
such a girl tribe there so i loved that
but like the physicality of the world we
were you guys i'm not watching that film
i was like you guys were running through
jungles jumping underwater and i saw she
was telling me that you guys were
swimming in a tank full of old food like
broccoli milk it was in milk to make it
murky and it was warm so they were like
heated it was like
ew guys please think about that you
gotta imagine swimming in a magical pool
yeah milk it was like broccoli
crock pot it was disgusting and like it
got progressively worse because it was
just like continuously cooking and it
smelled so bad it smelled soup my mom
said i smelled so bad i did like small
wigs after the shooting because i would
find broccoli like in areas that
broccoli should never be and your skin
was so pruning oh thank you yeah no my
hair fell out it was a disaster it was
an awesome but you know what i always
thought like corinne on set you were
like the mom of the group
i have energy no but it's it's honestly
amazing you're a total old soul have
people told you that yeah they have yeah
you definitely are and you you kept us
all in line because we were all younger
than you but you were if something
didn't sit right with you you'd be the
one to say something like you would say
oh that's not correct or we shouldn't do
that or if you're not comfortable you
should and i felt so good i felt so safe
around all the time
yeah hey guys i really don't think we
should be doing that yeah
because by the way you know sometimes
like people can take advantage of the
talent and like push and push and push
and
i'm afraid to say no sometimes but it
was so much fun i'm so happy that it's
full circle and that you're sitting here
now and i know it's like it's so weird
you guys like interviewing me i'm like
friends i know crazy actually i want to
bring up because you said it was like
friendship girl bond and now you're
doing the new show doll face or season
two yeah so honestly that was one of my
favorite shows on hulu i loved it and i
thought it was like i hope there was a
season two and i loved the point that it
was all about women feminism and power
and now you're on the show how has that
been it's been such an incredible
experience for me it's very similar to
47 meters where all the girls are so so
close i was actually nervous coming into
the second season because it was kind of
like being the new kid at school
okay they're all friends like what if i
come in like where do i sit for lunch
you know that was true
but they welcomed me in so much like so
comfortable the first day kat dennings
was like i love you bye and i was like
love you
she's
oh my god because you never know
sometimes you can go into that new
setting of girls and they could be catty
or you never know what to expect so
that's amazing tell us about your
character ruby oh yeah okay so i play
ruby she kind of comes in and tears up
the front the friend group a little bit
um it's actually interesting because the
character she has a father figure who's
a big music exec and so she's she's not
really used to having female friendships
so she's used to girls using her to get
connections and so i've talked a lot to
the show runner and the creator about
like my experience yeah in a similar
situation and like how ruby
she she's the toxic friend but maybe why
she's acting in that way and like her
insecurities and things like that and so
we've got to like make her a bigger
character because of that which has been
really peace that's really cool that
you're able to bounce off of your
personal experiences and then with the
producers and then apply it to your role
ruby
how has that been like
a part of corinne's life because i know
that we definitely come from a similar
situation both of our fathers are actors
do you feel like
you know
like ruby that you
sometimes are judged and and mislooked
and insecure because people expect
things from you like what's that been
like yeah it's interesting because ruby
does the exact opposite of what i do
where like she i feel like has such an
insecurity about people using her for
things that she's almost leaned into it
more where she's offering oh i'll do
this for you i'll do that i have all
these connections and that's her way of
connecting with people where i did the
exact opposite i was like don't bring up
my dad don't ever talk about him around
me don't ask me for anything like i'm so
sensitive to it like i don't even want
to like talk about him at all and i've
grown more comfortable with it yeah but
it was like a big i know it sounds weird
but like insecurity i had no you know
what i mean i'm like i just want to be
judged for for your perspective
yeah like who i am and not what i can
you know what door i can open for no
totally and i feel like that's we were
having this conversation the other day
about how sometimes when we feel like we
walk into a room we really want people
to judge us based on our own craft and
i'll go okay like
she's stallone's daughter fox's daughter
like she is it's nepotism or it's this
like no like i watch you like i watch
your film you work really hard you can
tell that you put in the time to the
craft you created your own podcast like
everything you do you put in the effort
it's all just about of course like we
acknowledge that we're in this
privileged position yeah being able to
get these jobs but
also we i want to be judged for what i'm
truly doing in this moment and not being
judged for something that i can't
control right do you feel like that
sometimes yeah i know i totally feel
like that i i'm curious if you guys feel
and this is something that i do maybe
because i'm a people pleaser but i feel
like i have to if i'm going into like
you know a room or a meeting and people
have these assumptions of me like i have
to over prove that i'm not yeah but i'm
humbled that i'm oh my god i almost do
it too much
because i'm like i really don't want
people to think i'm spoiled or i'm rude
or i'm anything
um and so i like over yeah you know what
i mean hundred percent
we kind of sometimes leave those
situations feeling almost exhausted
after we're like oh my god it felt like
we had to do a show and dance and it's
not us being fake but it's us like we
really are nice
it's hard because it's like we want to
prove so badly that we're not the kid
that they sort of conjured up in their
head like we're not uneducated and the
wild party hollywood child offspring and
like and so we feel like we're having to
constantly overcompensate and i mean i
even do that with like dating i can do
that with everyone because
it's weird that
you almost don't get a fair chance of
getting to show people this is who i am
like this is blank slate like because we
came from someone famous they're just
looping us in with that and then
especially being an actress yeah and
your dad's an actor it's like you get
judged even more and do you think that's
you know maybe you being on set have you
experienced this or auditioning have you
been treated differently or people look
at you differently i feel like once
you're on set and you're working like
everybody's equals i do think in like
the auditioning process like i feel like
maybe i stand out more and they're kind
of looking at me in a different way
they're like okay like is she gonna
actually show up and be good or are you
gonna like care about this audition and
things like that so that's where i feel
like i have to like show up more and i'm
like hi everyone like me and everyone
you know um so it's tough it's you know
i mean you guys you guys know it and i
feel like it's one of these things so it
makes us almost work harder and i do and
it does i actually think it's all
sometimes a blessing in disguise because
yes we're overcompensating being like
super nice super humble but that also
gives us a really great reputation like
okay they are really good people and
that almost forces us to constantly be
really good behavior i mean it's not
hard for us to be that way anyways but i
just like that it reinforces that we
need to be like yeah i will say sistine
on set you were like so punctual always
knew your [ __ ] we're like so on it but i
remember you telling me something like
your dad had told you if you're not did
you say this what if you're not maybe
you're making up like five minutes early
something like you were always saying
that and you were always like there on
time yeah you're really good about that
my my dad and my mom they both like
pounded this advice into sophia's and
our my head it was arrive early stay
late and work as hard as you can in
between yes and like that is why i will
never be late except it was late okay
you can't but i think i think that's
great advice thank you for saying that
yeah because um i think that's a good
thing to like remind people yeah yeah
say like if you're gonna make it
anywhere and do anything especially when
you're in this entertainment world be
always the first one there be always the
last one to leave and then make sure
you're putting in that time and effort
because people can see it today if
you're not putting in like that much
energy into something that you love like
your podcast like if you're not if you
are doing half the stuff people would
say oh like she doesn't really care
about yeah i know but you're like you
truly love it even your acting you're
like i'm gonna work and make ruby as
great as i can so i'm gonna talk to
these show runners i'm gonna talk to
these producers and be a professional
yeah and you have been like that which
is amazing yeah i mean you are working
on so many things it's actually crazy
because i get to sit back as the
supportive cheerleader side friend and
i'm like wow what are they talking about
you guys no i know but honestly i'm on
the show right now i'm a type of friend
where it's like i just like it makes me
so happy to see like people i know doing
really well yeah and like i've just been
watching you over the past two years and
like you're doing so many cool projects
like you did like a live uh acting
special and with jimmy fallon camel
kimmel yes
and then like your executive producer
and you were just on that the disney
plus movie like you are doing
so much stuff and cece said you're a dog
mom and your daughter i'm a new dog mom
how has that been well it's been great
but like like you said i'm very mom
energy so i'm like someone's like how
old is he like he's 13 weeks oh my god
we're doing this and he's learning this
he's with his trainer right now like
he's like i'm very typing it's a child i
know but i'm like i need to calm down
like what made you
well i just bought my first place and so
i was like i haven't
that's so exciting oh thank you and so
like i have the space for it and i'm
like okay now i have this big space and
it's just me by myself like walking
around the hallways i'm like you know
like i need a little companion yeah but
he really is a baby like he really
you posted a video of you getting the
dog crying i was like not me crying in
my bed too
that was my trip that tick tock which is
so imp like are you on it yes and it's
so embarrassing that my agency called me
and said is this your real account
no way oh i said um yeah it is my real
account and i'm trying okay you're like
this is not a phase do you guys do it
yeah so she has been on it since before
i don't think i've ever started it
no it's actually but it's so great what
are you posting like
a lot of ads
okay
actually this was funny she brought it
on right when quarantine hit and so we
were doing the dumbest videos yeah
because we had so much time we're like
okay you guys are going to do it did you
do the dances i was doing the dance i'm
not for the public we won't um i just
got it recently because everyone was
like you need to get it it's good for
like promo i have nothing and you want
to have your name yeah exactly and it's
a great form of promotion like i am
shocked how quick you can kind of blow
up on that
i i have not
but i feel really happy it'll hit dog
videos do so well yeah do funny dog
videos perfect those will do so i think
like i'm so creative but i can't think
of i'm so bad like it's bad oh no it is
well you know what you can do is cute
couple videos because you have a
boyfriend
you have a dog mom now your dog dad like
your boy
i was a little sensitive in the
beginning because i bought the i i
bought yeah yeah and i was like okay
he's my dog yeah the step dad and then
and then he was like
and then it hurt his feelings which is
fair so now he is his dad okay his dad
now stuffed up yeah i was like you're
the step dad he was like what he's like
you're the uncle so how did you meet
your boyfriend because we were kind of
i'm in a messy oh that's right okay
that's right so her boyfriend is a year
older than you so did you guys know each
other in school we like were crossing
paths
yeah but i had a long-term college
boyfriend at the time and we had like
this weird break
and i went to a you know a party at some
random person's person so i didn't know
and i walked in and i saw my boyfriend
and i literally went
him no way him and
oh i never did anything with it but all
i did was talk about him forever i was
like this guy joe hoot and joe and my
girlfriend's really what the [ __ ] are
you manifesting you don't know him like
you saw him once like shut the [ __ ] up
wait you didn't even talk to him at this
party maybe i went up and talked but we
didn't have like a moment i just saw him
and i what do you think it was though do
you think it was like physical
attraction or just like you had this
feeling like no it was like i've never
had before one he is six
six so he is very tall he's hard to miss
yeah so he like stood out wow yeah of
course but then also i got like hit i
was like i know this person's gonna be
in my life at some point whoa but then
it wasn't till years later where i like
broke up with that college boyfriend and
i was like okay who do i want to date
next
i liked so i purposely liked an old
instagram photo because i knew he would
know i was kind of like lurking oh wait
that's kind of i never knew that would
be a good thing it's a good so i liked
an old one 20 minutes later 20 minutes
later dms me hey long time no talk and i
was like
the phone wait can you just completely
rewrote
what is known to be absolutely
embarrassing right because if you
normally do it you're like [ __ ] like why
did i like this from 13 weeks ago no but
it was an old like baby photo so it was
like a cute photo
or like it wasn't baby like a toddler
and i like liked it and i'm not kidding
15 minutes later this man did you so did
someone tell you to do that or you just
like i'm gonna do it i just did it i
just knew it was going to work
that's a hat just like she freaking knew
that she was getting enough with him i
just knew it was going to work i just
started talking and it kind of just
worked out like that or was it easy in
the beginning or we went on a a date on
a book do you remember this that i went
on a date on a boat yes what oh my god
by the way this sounds like a very john
type i remember you told me this that's
what i said i remember you told me this
and i go i don't know what the second
date's going to be because just starting
on a boat first it was our first date so
he used to live on a boat um and so i
don't know why i would like think this
was okay but he was like do you wanna
have our first day on on this boat blah
blah blah we had drinks we're sailing
out i don't know this guy guys i'm on a
boat we're sailing away and i'm on find
my friends and so my friends are looking
at it and they just see my little bubble
just troubling the scene floating in the
ocean they go where the [ __ ] are you
like i'm on a boat with this guy i don't
know but i just know it's going to work
out like he could have dumped my body
a pirate
that would give me such claustrophobia
there's one thing i don't like and that
is boats and not because i don't like
the sea but i can't get off the boat oh
yeah i'm like if i don't like the group
i am with on the boat what am i going to
do but she wasn't what she knew it was
going to work but i just knew it it's so
not like me like i would never like sail
away with a man i didn't know but i i
just knew it was going to be sailing the
boat is just you and him yeah not on him
very romantic guys
and he had like string lights it was
john tucker must die by the way i
remember you had mentioned another date
that you guys went on it was something
like you were in this gorgeous
glamped-out rv yes yes can you explain
you go on the best dates and i need tips
from you because i planned at the worst
dates that was his birthday and i like
rented out this um yeah like a glamping
rv thing and like put like um confetti
everywhere and got him cupcakes and all
that stuff i'm you're very i mean i've
been bad and quarantined even done
anything so that's okay everyone got a
little bit lazy but you survived
quarantine which is a lot of people
can't say that
how long have you been dating now it'll
be
two and a half three years wow it was
literally we were like dating when we
were filming yeah what do you think has
been the best thing for the two of you
to keep this long-term relationship
going
i have to give it to him he's such a
good communicator and so like when we
have when there are issues i mean in
quarantine i was like if he would
breathe the wrong way like what are you
doing right right right
like walking like why are you walking
like that you know right and it's just
because we were sitting together like
staring at each other for months yeah
totally but i feel like when we were at
that point i was really good about like
i need space now and yeah okay like i
understand that and like we can really
right and you said that you were going
to move in with him right yeah wait so
what i died
we always say though we have such a hard
time with like anybody sleeping on our
beds like we even when we wait anywhere
people don't spend the night we don't
we're just like you know it's just a
couch or like i i need my own i need my
own bathroom i need my like i am a
person i feel like when you said you
need space i do need to you know i i
love relationships like i love being
with someone but at the same time i'm
like would you guys share a bathroom
because i always say what i do in the
bathroom no matter that's okay i heard
that that's the secret to keep a long
relationship it's not sharing a bathroom
i can't because so i i told you i bought
a place we have a three bedroom two bath
so like i have the master bath and he
has you know the other bathroom but it
has a shower and everything oh perfect
you know like and he has that one yeah
he doesn't need space he's fine he's a
boy yeah he has like two products are
you nervous are you excited like how is
it feeling with moving in with someone
for the first time well i have some time
we have till may i'm a little nervous
but we also did quarantine together so
like it's not going to surprise me how
he lives like all of a sudden he really
like does something [ __ ] weird
but i think just like balancing like our
own space yeah like i mean my place i
have like a guest bedroom so maybe some
nights you know how it's like we gotta
sleep in separate
like lived with before i've never lived
with anyone so is this like the only
thing i get nervous about saying okay
this is like a big first step like this
is a big move for like the relationship
is there have you guys thought about
that or is it we had our like talk of
like where is this going like do we want
to get married do we want to have like
we finally had that talk how did that go
i was so [ __ ] awkward oh they were
going to say awesome i was like yeah i
was so awkward i made it this like
formal he had brought up that he wanted
to have this talk but i was like i'm not
ready i'm an aquarius i was like no [ __ ]
this oh my god i can't all my best
friends are aquariuses okay yeah so like
we we're not committing like that so
finally i was ready and so like i made
it this thing where i texted him like
i'm ready to talk about our future and
then i came over and i was like would
you like to go to the bedroom and then
like i sat down on like a chair and was
like so
what does your fault
what are your intentions with this
relationship that's so weird about what
was your five-year plan yeah and he was
like we know each other you know
we're just like going to go along that
says a lot because i think a lot of guys
today are scared of commitment
yeah you know and so it is really hard
i'm sure like you know or you could see
your friends like dating and it's it's
hard out there i know i feel really bad
for my single friends because they're
really struggling on the apps and
they're bad for us too
are you guys on apps uh no i'm like when
i say single i mean i'm talking to zero
people like usually isn't that like a
good place to be actually yes and this
is the thing is that i before was like
i'm so bored like i like having i love
like talking to somebody at least but i
feel like for the first time i'm like
i'm just gonna let it
go as it may like the bright person will
come around like maybe i'll see a guy
that i used to go to school with and
they'd be like oh you know what like
that was
a cute guy like when i like is i'm gonna
use that trick actually but i think i
steal yours but i think it's nice
because it's like really the first time
i've ever been like oh i can focus on
myself yeah you know and that's like
also a blessing when you forget like
when you have to rely on someone or like
you when you're with someone you're
always having to which is also a good
thing but it's just
no when i broke up with my college
boyfriend i'd been dating for five years
it was the first time that i was alone
for the first time ever and i took a
solo trip by myself didn't tell my dad
because he would have stopped really and
where did you go costa rica i remember
you were telling me i was alone by
myself and i was just like i've never
been alone like i have to i'm a grown
woman like i can travel alone i had this
like very spiritual trip where i was
like falling in love with myself and it
was this whole thing let's talk about
this yeah i want to hear about this
actually what did you discover about
yourself what did you do in costa rica
alone so i went on like a retreat so
like i went alone but like there was
like an organizer okay like we went to
like this retreat center but we were
doing like meditations in like the
morning and like yoga and but a lot of
it was just like being on my own and
taking care of myself in a foreign
country
also where my parents really didn't know
where i was yeah yeah what did you tell
them i didn't tell my dad anything i
just went away for a week and i came
back and then i was like so i went to
costa rica because he would have flipped
yeah he flipped out no he i mean it was
too late yeah yeah yeah but he would
have sent like a bodyguard with me or
something
very similar you know like he would have
sent someone or he would have been like
no like i i found a place that you can
go that i know you'll be safe at is he
super overprotective
yes yes
especially with like physical safety
stuff like oh totally i mean like i feel
like i don't know if you get this stuff
too but we get a lot of like threats and
things like that i haven't had a whole
yeah yes no we've i've had stalkers on
campus at usc like really bad stuff so i
feel like yeah it's so scary i feel like
constantly it's like he has to have like
someone watching us no matter like
shadowing us and i feel like sometimes
he does it and doesn't tell us yeah
there's definitely people there's
definitely like i've seen some guy drive
his car out a couple times you're either
a stalker or you're some guy
i totally agree but so
i actually want to touch on this because
sophia was just mentioned that she had a
stalker come on campus at usc and
sort of growing up the way that we did
there was often a lot of like really
scary weird incidences that would happen
that like i wouldn't say like the normal
you know
kid had to go through yeah and you
mentioned that you are a big advocate of
mental illness and mental health and i
would love to know what sparked that for
you and and if that sort of upbringing
sparked any of that for you
yes definitely i
was diagnosed with anxiety when i was 14
like i was sitting in my english class
and my palms were sweating and my heart
was being out of my chest and i didn't
know what it was like i didn't anxiety
wasn't a thing when i was 14. we weren't
talking about it there wasn't mental
health hashtags and all that stuff and
so i didn't know what's going on so for
whatever reason i like again like i'm
very mom energy like go and tell my mom
i'm like i'm not feeling well and so
i've had the same therapist since i was
14 but i do think really yes i love over
a ten-year relationship oh 13 years wow
me and this woman
does she walk me down the aisle at this
yeah
she's a machine yes i've been to like
ten different therapists and i just
don't yeah i haven't just found the
right one yeah that's the thing it's a
little bit of like dating it is like to
go in and you have to just like and it
sucks because you don't want to have to
tell your whole story over and over
again yeah and now i'm at the point this
lady like she knows me she's like wait
this reminds me of the time when you
were this age remember this guys
so it's like talking to like a
girlfriend who knows like you know
backwards and forwards
but it was a really hard time when i was
first diagnosed because there's just no
conversation for mental health like no
one was talking about this stuff and i
felt like it was something i had to hide
i do feel like growing up the way we did
like i became like a perfectionist
because i didn't want to mess up i
didn't want people think badly of me
that's a lot of anxiety like not be a
human being you know literally my twin
because i was exactly yeah the same
anxiety that i had like mine went from
being
separation anxiety with my parents and
then went to my sisters and now i like i
am diagnosed with anxiety is a lot about
me messing up and not being perfect it's
like if i'm put in this position where i
can't control it and i can't make sure
it's perfect i get like so like sweaty
palms are bad like i can't breathe and i
feel like my thoughts are just racing
and i just it overwhelms you and i think
it also has to do with like
we
also since we are sort of held to this
standard of you must be if you're not
creating the same exact success as your
parents like you're a failed kid no one
i guess really puts that on us i
definitely feel like i put that on
myself and i know you put that on
yourself too and that also just causes
so much [ __ ] stress for no reason
having to like live up to this
expectation that you're like maybe i
won't amount to the same success but
doesn't mean i'm not happy or equally as
successful in different ways and yeah i
mean i think we're lucky that we're like
our you know well your mom is
famous as well but like
we're women and like our dad's career
like i'm never gonna be like you know
rocking it's totally different you know
we have they have different careers than
us you know and different skills and we
have different skills from them that
i've learned like oh like i can do this
this is something my dad can't do you
know exactly and so i feel like i've
learned through therapy to do that but
yeah that's like my biggest what were
the things that you think for your
anxiety that were triggers for you
that you saw like flaring up more
because i know for me also i've had days
where i've had anxiety attacks out of
nowhere like literally the best day ever
and all of a sudden i'm just feeling
horrible and i wake up in a horrible
mood or something i used to have social
anxiety i don't really have that as much
anymore
um i had like a physical safety thing
like a lot like actually just happened
the other day like this this delivery
guy showed up at my door knocked on the
door and then i'm like hi like sir what
are you and he's just looking at me and
i'm going oh my god this is one of my
stalkers and he's here to [ __ ] kill
me and i literally freaked the [ __ ] out
i like slammed the door shut and then
finally he walks up he's like hey i'm
from chanel i'm dropping off this you
know whatever he was a messenger but i'm
like why are you saying anything don't
look at me like this
you know i have ptsd from yeah you know
whatever all the crazy things you guys
have been through too so yeah i mean
right it's a
i don't know would you tap in on that
would you tap in on like some crazy
experience that you have a stalker
um i can because he's
ugh
i have a stalker that is no longer alive
really yes
it's that dangerous
so like we won't tap into it
i mean like that's what that's but
that's what people don't see and like
don't know about and i don't talk about
it it's it's really sad like we the the
letters and and the messages that we
receive and i mean it's really scary
even involving our little sister who's
you know away at college it's like we're
constantly worried that you never know
you really never yeah do you guys have
people who like think they're dating you
yes yeah yeah no that actually was the
one that came to campus and he was
coming to marry me yeah yeah that was
the same with the yes
but he was stalking me since i was like
13.
so that was the craziest part and that's
like a huge
huge thing for me safety as well with
like stalkers and i know cecine knows
like any time we had someone like
waiting for us by the walk like wanting
to take a photo i took that even though
they could be a fan it just like
triggered something we were getting
something just over quarantine
um because we weren't in a light so we
were staying at a different a house
outside of la and we were getting
messages saying like sophia i can see
you i'm standing outside of your bedroom
window right now i can see what you're
doing in your bedroom like stuff like
that i was just like panicking how could
you not leave with anxiety after i never
received all these messages i know i
went to my therapist to talk about this
stuff and she was like honestly like you
have every reason to be anxious about
that like there's not even something's
wrong with you like it's a scary
situation you shouldn't be yeah and she
told me she actually told me to talk to
you sistine because she was like is
there anyone else you know that like oh
my god i could even relate because like
you're worried
oh my god we can relate like
you have no idea that's why i'm like so
happy that you are an ambassador for
this mental health organization because
i wish growing up that it was more
talked about and i had to be and i feel
like you had to be the person that was
like no i have it like and i was the
first person to feel me going like i
need a therapist or i need someone to
talk to or something because
realistically everyone has some form of
something like no one is perfect we all
have our uh tics and things that trigger
us or make us feel sadder or happier or
anxious and so the fact that you're
doing this and you're making it more of
an awareness is so good and i feel like
is there anything that you guys are
doing right now that's um like a like a
movement right now like a hashtag or
anything that's like yeah i believe
mental health awareness week is in
october oh because that's coming up
mental health awareness month is may um
but i'm i'm like shooting a youtube
thing for them this week and so i'm
always worried i'm like whatever you
guys want me to do i'll do yeah i'm in
any way that i can i mean the the best
thing i ever did with them as i went to
washington dc and we lobbied congress
for mental health reform and we got it
passed and it was like the most special
thing in the whole world and i literally
was like okay this is like one of those
moments where you're like everything in
my life led up to this moment when
you're physically seeing the change
which is
worth it that's amazing i know a lot of
people we get a lot of messages from our
listeners out there and something that i
want to question you about because i
really don't know what to do i feel like
i
have always thought i was normal and
like i'm good and i guess what is normal
really but i i don't have anxiety like
sophia is the one that has anxiety so
it's not me i'm yeah i'm claiming it
yeah like sophia's got it for the both
of us and um but i was realizing over
the years like i just had like all of
these issues and underlying problems
that i would just sweep under the like
sweep another rug and then
once every six months they just build up
and i explode and i don't
i guess it was sort of a taboo topic but
i thought i was mentally strong enough
to
handle it myself so for someone like me
never seen a therapist never never
discussed their feelings ever because
thinking
i can handle them myself which i can't
definitely she doesn't
it's only when she explodes discuss it
it really comes out in the strangest
ways like i will be dealing with for
example the stress of going on that
movie and then i'll be crying about a
boy that i don't even care about and i
was like it's not about a guy like it's
something different so for someone like
me this number two therapist maybe wants
to seek therapy may be scared to commit
to it like what would be a good first
step
yeah it's tough i feel like there's one
there's a lot of stigma about therapy
and then there's like also like the
generational stigma like me maybe people
are parents generation like don't really
get it and don't understand it and
they're like well just like toughen up
or whatever maybe like maybe that's the
way you why you are that we were but
maybe not um i mean i would say for me
if you just start journaling like just
start like listening to your like you
can read your thoughts you're like that
sounds [ __ ] crazy like i did that
yeah
have you been journaling for a while
yeah i've been journaling since i was a
kid it was like such a cathartic because
that's what i do so see me really
i honestly think it's hilarious because
i read back to things i was like like my
high school boyfriend i'm like i think i
have to break up with them i'm just like
so dramatic i'm like oh my god why were
you thinking this way but you see
patterns yeah you can see patterns and
then you really like okay this is
something i want to talk about with
somebody
and i mean there's a lot of resources
you can use uh psychologytoday.com to
find a therapist i will say like it is
dating but once you find the right one
like i'm
13 years with this woman she's she's my
ride or my writer now she is ready she
does me better than anyone yeah and we
probably are like too close at this
point like it's great well i just like
text probably and be like well i think
that's amazing and i love that you
prioritize like your mental health and
your well-being and it's something i do
remember spending a lot of time with you
uh and and london and the in the dr was
that you really
uh
prioritize like your self-care routine
and like your routine is so important to
you and that's something i need to do
better is like prioritize a routine have
you guys ever meditated yes i can't sit
still yes you can i can't you see me
this episode is like this the whole time
i can't i mean
again meditation i'm like is it gonna
work for me no i'm just such a pessimist
no it will okay first of all there's
like how to start okay download
headspace or download the calm app and
literally three minutes well i have a
problem
because i tell her this all the time no
but i remember she doesn't listen to me
i had an issue with the call map because
they have those actors and musicians no
no start with headspace and i started to
get a little bit hot i was like because
murphy was talking talking about ireland
so kellyanne where he was telling her
calm down she's turning up
three minutes and just
gradually build it i'm not kidding i
meditate every day for like 30 minutes
30 minutes yeah see i can only wait for
15. 30 minutes every morning or when do
you do it basically if i'm not working
if i don't have to be on set at like 6
a.m but yeah you can sleep for 30
minutes yeah and then after it then i
journal it's like a whole hour i'm like
spending it's like this very spiritual
meditative state i'm in i love that you
don't know it's really i think that
you're really showing the importance of
prioritizing mental health before
anything yeah and i think that really is
like it is the thing that is the root
for everything you do in life i think
with your relationships with your family
your friends your boyfriend with your
job with how you react to things or with
people it's like i think people need to
remember like don't prioritize other
things first focus on you yeah see what
makes you happy keeps you centered calm
and then when you feel
stabled and strong enough that's when
you can kind of go okay like i am ready
for that relationship that is the
healthiest for me and that's kind of the
stage that you're in right yeah
definitely alone like you can just focus
on your mental health and take yourself
and then like that's when you start to
attract the right people oh totally and
i feel like that's been something i've
always been trying to work on like
mental health is not something you work
on just for a year and it just fixes it
it isn't going for an ongoing thing and
i think even this year i feel like every
year i'm like oh i figured it out but i
feel like this year like i really am
starting to figure things out and you
can figure it out at
eighteen thirteen twenty-five forty-five
like it doesn't matter that the corrine
you had said that you'd listen to the
sophia's mid quarter life crisis oh yeah
yeah yeah and that you could relate to
it because you should talk about that
because that was funny oh yeah they're
kind of cool it's not funny but you know
what i feel like people like it's i feel
like i'm all my friends are probably
like shut up sophia because i've already
been saying this little thing
if i had 10 seconds
no but yeah no no i was listening to it
on the way here and i was like oh i
totally went through that at that age
and it's just like i mean it's a lot of
it's just like the societal pressure of
like at this you were saying like at
this age you should do this you should
do that at you know now i'm around in
the corner i'm not i'm 27 but i'm like
i'm always 30.
everyone that's like over thirty seconds
already so bad i want to be 32. i feel
like that's my prime i'm gonna be like
fully put together but
um but no like i understand that feeling
and like that anxiety and i went through
it as well so like you're not alone and
you're not crazy and also it's so funny
can i say that i can say this we have a
project that i'm developing called
quarter life crisis shut up so do you
stop working it is a thing
because it is normal friends
i cannot believe crazy how much you you
balance like how how do you balance it
all you do so much i have a life coach
okay see i have a life because
his podcast and he was literally saying
you can have a therapist and that can do
as much as it can for you but then you
do need a life coach because that also
is like takes you a whole new level
yeah this woman has changed my life
because i had so many little projects
here and there i was like okay i'm
developing that i'm writing the script
i'm doing this i'm like how do i how do
i balance this because i don't have a
nine to five job i don't clock and i
don't work out and i have my podcast
whatever and so every tuesday except for
today she canceled on me whatever um i
meet with her and she goes through all
of my projects we prioritize them and
then we put them into my calendar so
she's like wednesday you're gonna work
on this thursday you're gonna do this
and then we do we start with work
because i'm so discombobulated and then
it's like relationships and then it's
like okay when are you gonna make that
date night with joe okay let's put it in
here and when are you gonna plan it like
wow what time are you gonna plan it okay
friday at this time like it is
i couldn't function without her please
oh my god i need to hear this because
i'm all over the [ __ ] face yeah i
feel like i my brain is in 10 different
places and i want to get everything done
but then you procrastinate the idea of
getting all these things done stresses
me out and then when i write it it's oh
my god do you hear me i'm like this is
amazing no it is it's all my anxiety
really it really really does and so yeah
i have my i feel like a crazy person and
i know it's extremely privileged to be
able to do this but like i have my
therapist and i have my life coach and
like you know like they're they're
tackling like two sides of my life yeah
yeah and i think that that's like the
best balance it's like you have someone
that tells you exactly how to structure
and by the way like you can teach your
friends that and i think also for
listeners that are hearing like it kind
of reminds me oh like if i feel like i'm
all over the place but then i'm also
doing nothing at the same time like the
best way to get things done is to really
like have a calendar and book things out
like okay i'm gonna work out at this
time i'm gonna do because like you can
spend i even say this because i have a
book club i'm like you can spend out of
some time a week ten minutes a day to
read or something yeah you can find that
time to focus on you and to focus on
work and the relationship which is all
how you structure it exactly and my my
life coach like if i'm filming during
the day she'll be like okay you need to
schedule 45 minutes at the end of the
day to just do nothing i don't want to
do anything i don't have your phone on
and like i have to put like do nothing
like on my calendar and like i get a
reminder and so it's not just work but
it's like also scheduling in that
self-care like read for the book club
like putting that in your calendar as if
it's like a meeting i actually love that
idea i do too i feel like we need to do
that i need help i need help i'll i'll
send you her her please yeah she loves
she's the best
i know this needs like help
health
corrine you are amazing yeah you are
amazing you guys are honestly this is so
fun because we were talking about we've
actually been wanting to have you on for
a while but this is also a situation we
want to be legitimate too no you were
like the second person we wrote down
yeah and like our our dream guest list
when we first developed
you were like the second now i want you
guys all you guys have to come on my
podcast yes actually time plug your
socials like where can people find you
in your podcast oh yeah my my my socials
at karen fox please don't follow me on
tech talk please please don't follow
around tick tock please don't take time
being so serious i'm gonna go delete it
right now i can find it i have a podcast
called am i doing this right it's at am
i doing this right pod on instagram
um and yeah that's really it's great
corrine i love you guys
this space is so [ __ ] cool you guys
should watch on youtube yeah yeah yeah
it's so good no but i i forgot how much
i missed you thank you so much for this
so much fun
yes
thank you guys so much for tuning in we
will see you next tuesday
[Music]
you